[Music]
please
please have a seat
good afternoon and welcome to the white
house
i know this is not a it's kind of an old
place for some of the guys that are
coming here
but uh thank you all very much and to
all the cabinet members elected
officials that are here and
and uh and former elected officials like
joe lieberman and
a good friend is here
so many
critical people and important people
i want to thank the vice president and
vice president harris and the second
gentleman for allowing us
to join them no for joining us
but it is always a pleasure when you get
to hang out together on monday we
celebrated the independence of our
nation
a nation always a work in progress
in creation of possibilities
fulfillment of promises
that's the american story
it's not a simple one
it's never been a simple one but the
fourth of july week reminds us what
brought us together long ago and still
binds us
binds us at our best
we strive for what we strive for we the
people
doing what we can to ensure the idea of
america
a cause of freedom
shines like the sun
to light up the future of the world
that's the soul of our nation
that's who we are as americans and
that's what we see
an extraordinary extraordinary group of
americans up here in this stage that i
have the honor to recognize today with
the presidential medal of freedom our
nation's highest civilian award
simone biles the most decorated american
gymnast in history
everyone stops
everything every time she was on camera
just to watch this
when we see her compete we see unmatched
unmatched power and determination grace
and daring
a trailblazer and a role model
when she stands on the podium she sees
we see what she is absolute courage to
turn personal pain and a greater purpose
to stand up and speak for those who
cannot speak for themselves
today
she adds to her metal count of 32. i'm
going to find room
32
olympic and world championship medals
at age 25
the youngest person ever to receive the
medal of freedom
[Applause]
there's so much more to give a fellow
elite athlete
megan
megan repino where megan
megan is one of the most accomplished
soccer players and the first soccer
player to receive the medal of freedom
beyond the world cup titles the olympic
medals megan is a champion for essential
american truth that everyone
everyone is entitled to be treated with
dignity and respect everyone
along with her incredible teammates of
the united states women's national team
and by the way my son hunter and
daughter-in-law are here his daughter
was a great high school athlete and she
was enough so excited to be with you
when you when you won the national when
you won the the championship and walking
off the field and i said we said hi to
you she said
i was busy
so when she wins again i hope i see her
she'll say i think i know that guy
maybe
it depends defense
megan did something really consequential
she helped lead
the change for perhaps the most
important victory
for
anyone on her soccer team or any soccer
team equal pay for women
and megan like simone i hope there's
room for this medal between all the
other awards you and sue have received
during your rec your remarkable careers
and your reckless play i'm watching you
my lord you have such
you are good
simone and megan would be the first to
acknowledge they stand on the shoulders
of those who came before them
like air force colonel brigadier general
retired we'll move on
woman is one of the most decorated women
ever to serve in the united states
military she enlisted in the 1950s
because she wanted to be a leader
she did that and more becoming the first
women on almost every leadership role
she held in only 30 years in uniform
shattering conventions shaping a new
tradition of our military
and she couldn't stop after retirement
she led the creation of the woman's
military service for american memorial
and the gateway of arlington national
cemetery the first museum is kind so
that we may know and be inspired by not
just her story but by the stories of
millions of women who serve this nation
in uniform
as a 23 year old student at fisk
university diane nash received a phone
call from attorney general robert
kennedy's top deputies
warning her about the violence at the
next stop of the freedom ride she
organized across the south she replied
and i quote
we all signed our last will and
testament before they left
we know someone will be killed but we
cannot let violence overcome
non-violence
look at that
unmistakable courage and unshakeable
courage and leadership diana shapes some
of the most important civil rights
efforts in american history
a key architect of the city movement in
nashville
after four little girls were murdered
the 16th street baptist church in
birmingham
she called for a non-violent movement
across alabama that planted the seas
became the selma campaign two years
later her activism echoes the call of
freedom around the world today
and yet she is the first to say the
medal is shared with hundreds of
thousands of patriotic americans of
sacrifice so much for the cause of
liberty and justice for all
and by the way she asked me to make sure
to add that because she didn't want to
take all the credit herself
dr king rosa parks and claudette colvin
and john lewis and other giants of our
history needed a lawyer for their fight
for freedom
you know who they call they call a guy
named fred gray
one of the most important civil rights
lawyers in our history
fred's legal brilliance and strategy
desegregated schools and secured the
right to vote he went on to be elected
as one of the first african-americans to
alabama state legislative sense
reconstruction
an ordained minister he imbued a
righteous calling that touched the soul
of our nation
and at
91 years young he's still practicing law
he's still
and he's still keeping the faith in the
best of america
and the best of america includes
raul roll you're something else man
no you really are you really are
uh
rohl was a son and father who fled
violence in mexico and a mother who was
a multi-generation texan her old dream
of american dream from san juan texas in
the lower rio grande valley he served
with honor in the united states air
force then turned a small civil rights
group into one of the nation's most
important ones for over 30 years as
president national council for la raza
raul was an undaunted leader in the
struggle for civil and human rights for
latino americans
challenging the powerful on behalf of
the powerless never forgetting where he
came from and the promise of this nation
born in brownsville texas julie garcia
became a professor at local community
college
i know i'm biased since jill is a
community college professor but
community college professors are the
best that's
i've learned
teaching isn't what she or jill does is
who they are
it's who juliet is
over the course of her nearly 30-year
career she helped transform her
community college into the university of
texas at brownville where she became his
president and the first hispanic woman
to serve as the college president in
american history
believe in education as a cornerstone of
our democracy she created a culture of
excellence affirmation intellectual
curiosity for generations of students
many of the first in their families to
go to college
and who see their american dream through
her and because of her
other than my family the biggest impact
in my life were the nuns at holy rosary
and santolina's schools the sisters of
saint joseph and clemont delaware
you think i'm joking i'm not
nuns never forget a thing
never
and by the way i was doing villanova's
commencement of one of my nuns from
school was getting her doctorate degree
i presented it to her
and she said that was pretty good job
but you said you instead of me at the
time
they taught me in school they helped me
i used to study very badly
they gave me confidence they gave me
confidence that i could do anything they
really did
for so many people and for the nation of
sister simone campbell as a gift from
god
for the past
in the past 50 years
she embodied the belief in our church
that faith without works is dead
and will know me for what you will know
me for what i do
and what you do the least of the you do
unto me
that's sister simone that's what she
does the nuns on the bus were simply
simply remarkable
i wasn't supposed i'm not going to do
this they told me not to i'm going to do
it anyway i'm telling a story
i went over to see pope john excuse me
pope benedict
uh in his last
couple of months we didn't know at the
time
and we had a long conversation he's a
great theologian a very conservative
theologian and my avocation is theology
you come to my house there's a whole
wall on comparative theology i know alan
and uh
um and so we finished the conversation
he's very generous and he put his hand
across the desk and put it on my hand he
said can i ask you a favor and then i
was vice president mr vice president i
said of course you're holding this
he said i'd like some advice you have
any advice for me i said it'd be
presumptuous to me to give you advice
your homeless he said no really and i
smile and i said well one piece of
advice
i said i'd go easy on the nuns and
they're more popular than you are
the fact that six weeks later he retired
i don't know
but sister you're standing up
was a big deal
a big big deal
becoming a lawyer to represent the poor
and the left behind a decade ago as the
nation was debating the affordable care
act
and the values of our budgets
there she was
leading a group of nuns in a nationwide
bus campaign
to make the case the moral case that
health care is a right in this country
not a privilege and the obligation to
help other people most in need
compassionate and brave
humble and strong today sister simone
remains a beacon of light
she's the embodiment
of a covenant of trust hope and progress
of our nation
and i call him i'm happy to call him my
friend thank you sister
another dear friend of mine and the
reason why back in delaware in the greek
community i've known is joe bidenopolis
you think i'm joking father knows i'm
not
father asked me whether i'm still
blessing my we roman catholics bless
ourselves down here into the left
shoulder
greek catholics go down and to the right
shoulder i find myself being more greek
sometimes than others get me in trouble
you want to know how i believe father uh
carl lotus
you uh
more than 50 years your leadership in
the greek orthodox
archdiocese of america has mattered to
every every prelate in the greek church
you've been an incredible leader father
a man of deep moral clarity and calling
he's advised generation of presidents
and parishioners and unmatched with
unmatched humility and grace
i've traveled the country in the world
with him including father alex's
homeland in greece to strengthen the
bonds between two nations founded on the
belief that democracy is the way
and on more than one occasion father
alex and i've had the honor to visit his
all hole in the security patriarch
patriarch bartholomew which is a great
honor this is the 100th anniversary of
the greek orthodox church in america we
honor one of the most dedicated leaders
my dear friend father alex
speaking of faith when you meet gabby
giffords congresswoman giffords be
reminded
[Applause]
and the power of public service
elected by the people of her hometown of
tucson arizona
because they trusted her
they trusted her they still trust her
they believed in her they learned and
they learned as a nation
what they learned and what the whole
nation has learned she's the embodiment
of the most of them the most of a single
significant american trait
never ever give up
dad hunt's grandfather used to have an
expression he said
never bend never bow
never yield never give up just get up
joey just get up
proof that will not grow numb to the
epidemic of gun violence in this nation
proof that we can channel the pain and
sorrow we see too often in america into
a movement that will prevail
with her husband
united states senator mark kelly who by
the way was that astronaut you all
remember
she is more consequential i acknowledge
but they're helping power that movement
on monday will celebrate the most
significant gun safety law in 30 years
because of them and because of the
families like theirs all across america
gabby is one of the most courageous
people i have ever known
[Applause]
one of the most decent stand-up genuine
guys i've ever served with and i serve
with a lot of senators is this guy alan
simpson
alan's the real deal
former united states senator from his
beloved wyoming a republican we served
together in the united states senate for
nearly two decades
one of the great things about allen is
he never takes himself too seriously
nor takes me seriously
all kidding aside this is the real deal
this is one of the finest men i've ever
worked with
at his core
he's always believed in the common good
and what's best for the nation
we didn't agree on everything all we
read in a whole heck of a lot
he allowed his uh
uh he he he never allowed his his his
i don't know his
party or his state or anything getting
away what he thought was right
he allowed his conscience to be his
guide and he believed in forging real
relationships even with people on the
other side of the aisle
proving we can do anything we work
together as the united states of america
it matters it matters it matters
we need more of your spirit back in the
united states senate on both sides of
the aisle
just ask keizer khan
who studied the us constitution as a law
student in pakistan
inspired by its meaning he immigrated to
america with his wife and their young
family
when they were very little but fully
believing in the promise of this nation
they watched their middle son enlist the
united states army
with his own dreams to be a military
lawyer but ultimately sacrificed himself
to serve his fellow soldiers
and we all watched as the oldest and
darkest forces of hate emerged in new
ways only to meet the strength
goodness and decency of this gold star
american family
late in late november 2016
i invited the cons to the vice
president's residence at naval
observatory for a diwali reception
an irish catholic vice president of
muslim gold star family at a reception
of deserving a hindu holiday
that and being very serious
that's the america that we know
that's the america he and i and most of
you i pray god believe in
we we were parents united by the pain of
losing the peace of our souls
and finding the purpose to live a life
worthy of them
after today's
uh father's medal of freedom will rest
next to the son's bronze star and purple
heart
and uh
keizer khan you will continue to carry a
copy of the constitution they didn't ask
you but i imagine it's still in your
pocket
as a reminder of the charge that has to
be kept
she's 18 years old sandra lindsay
immigrated to queens new york from
jamaica
to pursue her dream of becoming a nurse
as director of nursing and critical care
at a hospital in queens during the
height of the pandemic she poured her
heart into helping patients fight for
their lives and to keep their fellow
nurses safe
and when the time came she was the first
person in america that fully vaccinated
outside of clinical trials
sandra as i told you before if there's
any angels in heaven they're all nurses
male and female
no for real
they really are many of you who've spent
a lot of time in the hospital as some of
us have you know
doctors let you live nurses male and
female make you want to live
make you want to live santa's
vaccination card and hospital scrubs and
badge are part of the smithsonian
national museum of american history
exhibit on covent 19.
today
she receives our nation's highest
civilian honors
[Applause]
and the man who couldn't be here today
but wants to be wanted to be denzel
washington
one of our greatest actors in american
history academy awards golden globes
tony awards
wide acclaim and admiration from
audiences and peers around the world
he couldn't be with us today but i'm
i'll be giving him this award at a later
date when he's able to get here
i'll now turn to the three medalists who
are being awarded the medals
posthumously
to the families i know receiving this
award on behalf
of their loved one is bittersweet
it brings its honor but it brings back
everything in its heart
it brings you uh reminds you of the day
that you lost them
but i know
anything uh that i and i appreciate your
willingness to be here on this day
we've already seen more tech
technological change in the last 10
years than almost every before in
history
we're going to see a lot more change in
the next 10 years
and much much more of that is because of
steve jobs
not just because
[Applause]
not just because of his innovations in
the message inventions revolutionized
personal computing and our way of life
it's for his embodiment of a core
american character that he believed was
with each of us
character that tested contested his
setback in failure character that's true
and perseverance and daring character
defined by what we leave on this earth
when our time comes
and what steve left us is something
special
technology the capacity to improve our
lives in ways that haven't even yet been
thought of
and the love of his family
lorraine
powell jobs and their children who i had
the great honor of working with the camp
when i was doing the cancer moon shot
in the previous administration
they carry on this incredible legacy of
doing big things perhaps biggest of all
helping us and cancer as we know it
because it matters
it matters
it matters to people who need help is
why they do it and matter to steve jobs
richard trumka
he said about unions quote we do
america's work
no one did more work for american
workers than he did
for rich
his work was synonymous with the word
that defined his life dignity
dignity
dignity that comes with a good paying
job that builds a good and decent middle
class life
and his work was fierce
always trying to do the right thing for
working people
fighting for them protecting their wages
their safety their pensions they earned
and deserved
fighting for the worker power and for
america itself and our economic might
and dynamism
and more than 30 years of friendship
he's always honest fair and tough and
trustworthy
the guy you want your corner
in fact i was in cleveland yesterday
announcing one of the most significant
actions to protect pensions from
millions of workers and retirees in 50
years
barbara rich jr and the family
we felt him there we fell in there with
us and we talked about him and we feel
him here today
rich trumka was the american worker
was
[Applause]
when i was a young man
too young to be serving the senate but
early enough old enough to get elected
you have to
you can't get
you can't be sworn in until you turn 30
but you can elect it before that i got
elected 17 days before that
and i had the great honor because of a
guy named mansfield the majority leader
from montana to put me on a very coveted
committee at the time the foreign
relations committee
that's when i first met john mccain a
couple years later
he was a navy liaison
in the united states senate and liaison
to our committee
when we traveled we traveled with the
navy liaison personnel
john and i traveled the world together
literally traveled the world together we
became friends we agreed a lot more than
we disagreed on and although he was my
navy liaison i turned to him for advice
lots of times when we were talking about
foreign policy issues abroad
but the two things we never talked about
we never talked about
his imprisonment in the hanoi hilton
nor the death of my wife and my daughter
the pains were significantly different
but somehow
we seemed to sort of understand one
another
it was a long time ago
we both wanted to make things better for
the country that we both loved
and that never wavered
in fact
i admit to my democratic friends
i'm the guy that encouraged john to go
home and run for office
for real
because i knew what incredible courage
intellect
and
conscience he had
we used to argue like hell on the senate
floor
but then we go down have lunch together
afterwards as you remember
we ran against each other which i didn't
like on tickets to the highest office in
the land i was a candidate for vice
president he was the candidate for
president
i never stopped admiring john
never said a negative thing about him in
my life because i knew his honor
his courage and his commitment
that was john mccain
and the code he inherited from his
family that served before him is passed
on to his brothers sisters
children grandchildren today
cindy
madame ambassador
and the family i'm honored you have to
accept this medal on his behalf
as they say in the senate a point of
personal privilege
i was uh staffing john was staffing me
on a trip to asia
in the late 70s
and we stopped in
where there you are we stopped in hawaii
and uh cindy i think you were there on
vacation
and uh
and you were talking to my wife jill
and uh
john kept looking at her
and he talked about her so
jill and i did something which was a
little presumptuous we made sure they
introduced one another
he still owes me
i think it's the best thing we ever did
for john
the very best
[Applause]
that's true that's what he talked about
when we left
and he didn't take long to call you did
he when he got back
my fellow americans
please congratulate this year's
presidential medal of freedom
[Applause]
now i'm going to ask the military aide
to read the rest of the citations as we
present the medals please be seated
simone biles
[Applause]
overcoming great odds simone biles is
the most decorated american gymnast in
history
a former foster child who became a
once-in-a-generation athlete
transforming her sport with artistry and
degrees of difficulty that reimagine
what is possible
with absolute courage and honesty she
expands the legacy of our greatest
champions who challenge the powerful and
speak up for justice and the wellness of
body and mind
leaning on faith in god and family
simone biles is an inspiring symbol of
strength
grace and pride in those three letters
usa
[Applause]
right
[Applause]
simone campbell
[Applause]
inspired by nuns in catholic school
sister simone campbell has dedicated her
life to the suffering and the searching
for nearly 50 years as a nun and an
attorney she has led organizations that
provide free legal services to the poor
and advocate for workers and immigrants
her moral courage helped pass the
affordable care act and guide the nuns
on a bus tour
across america to protect the
impoverished
with humility and fearlessness sister
simone embodies the blessing of faith in
god and our obligations to one another
as fellow americans
[Applause]
[Applause]
garcia
[Applause]
born in a texas border town dr juliata
garcia became the first in her family to
graduate from college and the first
mexican-american woman to lead an
american college or university
over two decades she transformed her
hometown university of texas brownsville
into a center of excellence for
countless students who were inspired by
her example
a trailblazer and a mentor dr garcia is
considered one of our nation's top
university administrators who
understands the power of education as
the great equalizer in america
[Applause]
back
[Applause]
gabrielle giffords
[Applause]
[Applause]
a daughter of tucson arizona former u.s
representative gabrielle giffords
epitomizes public service voters elected
her five times to state and federal
office
even after that january day in 2011 that
shocked our nation's conscience she
summoned the courage to keep serving
she learned to walk speak and write
again
with the support of her husband u.s
senator mark kelly
she turned pain into purpose as one of
the most powerful voices working to end
gun violence in america
because of her lives will be saved and
america will be safer
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
fred david gray
[Applause]
when rosa parks refused to move to the
back of the bus fred gray represented
her in front of the courtroom
just as he did for martin luther king jr
and countless marchers for justice
risking his own safety he helps secure
voting rights desegregate schools and
win other battles for the soul of our
nation
a patriarch of a family and a movement
fred gray is a lawyer by trade and a
preacher at heart who follows the
command to hate evil love good and
establish justice in the gate
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
lorraine powell jobs accepting on behalf
of steve jobs
[Applause]
few people in history embody the
american spirit of innovation like steve
jobs
the adopted son of high school educated
parents he redeemed soda bottles to pay
for his meals after dropping out of
college
at every turn of life he dared to think
different
as the co-founder of apple he created
one of the most important companies in
history bringing computing into homes
and phones and revolutionizing our way
of life
a true visionary a beloved husband and
father steve jobs embodied that most
american of questions what's next
[Applause]
alexander
carlos
[Applause]
proto-pester of the economical
patriarchate the former vicar general of
the greek orthodox arc archdiocese of
america father alexander carlusos is a
humble servant of god and the embodiment
of the ancient idea that binds two great
nations democracy
through more than 50 years of service
with moral clarity love of family and
pride in the greek american community
the man known simply as father alex to
presidents and parishioners alike
inspires us to believe in the power of
we the people
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
khan
[Applause]
a son of farmers in pakistan khazir khan
studied law inspired by the u.s
constitution
he met and married a college classmate
gazala and together they immigrated to
america
a brilliant lawyer he watched their
three sons follow their american dreams
including their middle son
army captain amayan khan who enlisted
during the during college and paid the
ultimate sacrifice in iraq
the father of a gold star muslim family
khazir khan turned pain into purpose to
become a foremost defender of the ideals
of our constitution and the embodiment
of its highest ideals
[Applause]
sandra liza lindsey
[Applause]
an immigrant from jamaica sandra lindsay
is a nurse in queens new york and the
first american to be vaccinated against
covet 19 outside of clinical trials
at the height of the pandemic she
directed a team of nurses as they worked
tirelessly to save patients while
risking their own lives when the kova 19
vaccine became available she was a ray
of light in our nation's dark hour and
continues to champion vaccinations and
mental health for health care workers
she represents the best of america
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
cindy mccain accepting on behalf of john
s mccain iii
[Applause]
john mccain was a giant among americans
from a family of patriots a genuine hero
who endured unspeakable torture as a
prisoner in the war in vietnam
a true public servant elected twice to
the u.s house of representatives and six
times to the u.s senate by the people of
arizona and nominated for the presidency
by the republican party
respected around the world he was an
eternal optimist who believe in
consensus character and putting country
first
his legacy continues to challenge us to
cherish integrity and serve with courage
and conviction
[Applause]
[Applause]
diane j nash
[Applause]
a fearless leader of the freedom rides
and nashville sit-in movements diane
nash was a fierce light in darkness
she did more than dream a better america
she helped build one
as a founder of the student on violet
coordinating committee in the 1960s
she's led some of the most important
20th century civil rights campaigns that
inspire activism around the world to
this day
for her strategic savvy and absolute
courage america's americans owe a debt
of gra a debt of gratitude tied diane
nash for helping forage a path toward a
more perfect union
[Applause]
[Applause]
megan rapino
[Applause]
world cup champion olympic gold gold
medalist named the world's best women's
soccer player megan rapino is one of
america's great athletes
known for her creative play and
leadership she also leads with a fierce
will off the field
a champion protecting the rights of
fellow
lgbtqi plus americans
a leader on the u.s women's national
team
perhaps the most dominant of any team in
any sport in their successful fight for
equal pay
megan rapino challenges and inspires
millions of people who believe in
themselves and the possibilities of our
nation
[Applause]
[Applause]
allen k simpson
[Applause]
an army veteran and public servant alan
simpson served with conviction and
integrity for 18 years as a republican
u.s senator from his beloved state of
wyoming despite increasing polarization
he brought people together with wit and
wisdom to make progress and find common
ground
never afraid to stand up for what he
felt was right he worked on pressing
issues like campaign finance reform and
marriage equality
alan simpson exemplifies our national
ideas of civil discourse responsible
governance and public service
[Applause]
look up
[Applause]
nice
richard trumka jr accepting on behalf of
richard l trumpka
[Applause]
the son of a coal miner richard trumka
followed his father into the mines to
later become the president of the united
mine workers and president of the
afl-cio
he never forgot where he came from and
always fought for the dignity of working
people
he built worker power by speaking truth
to power
knowing that the middle class built
america and unions built the middle
class
no one did more in the last half century
to build unions than richard trumka did
a beloved husband father and grandfather
he was the american worker
[Applause]
wilma l fought
[Applause]
retired air force brigadier general
wilma is one of the most decorated women
in the history of the united states
military
enlisting in the 1950s over the next 28
years she would serve in vietnam europe
and across america continually rising in
rank to become the first woman to hold
every job she ever had
she was awarded the legion of merit
bronze star and more
in retirement she spearheaded the
nation's first major national memorial
honoring the nearly three million women
who have served in uniform further
cementing her place in american history
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
children
raoul is aguirre
[Applause]
more
born to a mexican-american family in the
san juan valley raul izaguera saw a
better world beyond a lifesaver in
segregated south texas
after serving in the air force he became
one of our nation's preeminent civil
rights leaders as president of the
national council for la raza
over 30 years he has forged immeasurable
progress on voting rights education and
more to deliver the promise of america
to millions of latino americans
in service to our nation he has helped
ensure that america remains a land of
possibilities
[Applause]
mmm
[Applause]
this is america
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
folks
this concludes
this event
but uh we have a reception
i hope you stay and enjoy it again
thank you thank you thank you all
ladies and gentlemen please remain in
your seats as the president vice
president second gentleman and medalist
depart the east room thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
the answer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you